اذا مشاهدينا توسعت رقعه المواجهات في
السودان مع ضبابيه في المشهد الميداني ففي
الخرطوم الجيش عزز وحداته بنشر موسع
للدبابات في بعض المناطق اما في مرايي فقد
استعادت قوه دعم السريع سيطرتها على
المطار من الجيش الذي يستخدم وفق مراسل
للجزيره سلاح الطيران في المعارك المشهد
الميداني نتابعه في هذا التقرير
لا شيء محسوم في السودان سوى ان المواجهات
مستمره وتتصاعد وتييرتها وسط غياب حسم
ميداني في مواقع الاشتباكات الاستراتيجيه
حتى الساعه
المواجهات في العاصمه لا تزال على اشدها
وتتركز حول نقاط توصف بالسياديه البدايه
من القصر الجمهوري اذ اكد مصدر عسكري
للجزيره ان افرادا من الدعم السريع يوجدون
داخل القصر محاصرين بالكامل واضاف المصدر
ان وحدات من الجيش تصدت لهجوم الدعم
السريع على مقر القياده العامه للجيش
وتوقع المصدر العسكري ان يستخدم الجيش
تعزيزات الى العاصمه قال المصدر انها
ستكون كفيله بحسم القتال مع جيوب
الميليشيات في وقت وجيز حسب تعبيره
وتستمر المواجهات في مناطق كوبر والسكه
الحديديه وحي الوابورات بالخرطوم بحري
واكد مراسل الجزيره ان الاشتباكات لم تخفض
في منطقه شرق النيل شرقي الخرطوم مع تضارب
الروايات بين الجانبين
الى مراوي حيث الوضع مشتعل منذ اليوم
الاول
استعادت قوات الدعم السريع السيطره على
المطار في اليوم الثالث من القتال بعد
استقدام تعزيزات للمنطقه ما ادى لفقدان
الجيش سيطرته على المكان
ونقل مراسل الجزيره ان الجيش السوداني
يستخدم الطائرات في المعركه الدائره وتحدث
مراسلنا عن وقوع اصابات في عمليات الكر
والفر بين الجانبين وفي نيال بولايه جنوب
دارفور غربيه البلاد افد مراسل الجزيره
بان معارك عنيفه شهدتها المدينه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع حول مقر قياده الجيش
وان اسواق نيالا شهدت اعمال نهب وحرق
واسعه
اما ولايه البحر الاحمر فيقول الجيش انه
السيطره على جميع مقر قوات الدعم فيها بعد
ان كان قد بسط سيطرته امس على مدينه
بورتسودان
ينضم الينا من اسامه سيدي احمد مراسل
الجزيره اسامه في الساعه الاخيره اشرت الى
هدوء حذر يسود مروي مع استمرار سيطره
الدعم السريع على المطار هل تغير شيء في
هذا المشهد
حصل لم يتغير شيء من المعطيات الميدانيه
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه الوضع يظل
كما هو حتى هذه اللحظه على الاقل يعني
المعطيات الميدانيه تشير هنا الى ان قوات
الدعم السريع يعني
تفرض سيطرتها الكامله بحسب
مصادر من الجيش السوداني وايضا تاكيدات
قوات الدفاع قوات
الدعم السريع نفسها على هذه على مطار مروي
الدولي اذا
الجيش ايضا قال انه خلال الساعات القليله
القادمه سيكون له يعني واقع جديد خاصه انه
في نيته كما تشير بعض المصادر في الجيش
السوداني انه سيقوم
باعاده بسط سيطرته الكامل على المطار ولكن
لم يكشف المصدر العسكري عن طبيعه الخطوات
العسكريه والميدانيه التي
يتخذها الجيش السوداني خلال ساعات القليله
القادمه لاستعاده
السيطره الكامله على مطار مري الدولي ولكن
الوضع يبقى كما هو ولكن قبل ثلاث ساعات او
اكثر هناك نشاط
لطائره حربيه كانت تجوب سماء مدينه مروي
ويعني تقوم بعمليه
ربما عمليات عمليات حربيه ضد مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع علمنا من شهود عيان ان قوات
الجيش السوداني قامت باغلاق كبري الصداقه
بمدينه مروي وقالت ان قال انها هذه الخطوه
من شانها ان توفر السلامه للمواطنين
في ذات الوقت فيما يبدو انها تريد منع اي
شكل من اشكال التحركات بحريه
لسيارات الدعم السريع نعم حسن
عندما يتوعد الجيش السوداني بالعمل على
استعاده السيطره السيطره على مطار مروي هل
هناك تحركات في اماكن معينه او امدادات او
حشود لقوات الجيش
ملاحظه في في مناطق ما بمحيط المطار او
حتى في داخل مروي
طبعا الجيش لديه مواقع
ترتكز فيها الياته هناك اسلحه ثقيله هناك
دبابات يريد بها ان ينهي بها هذه المعركه
على الاقل في محيط مطار مروي الدولي ولكن
لم تكشف لنا مصادر الجيش طبيعه
الميدان في هذه اللحظات ولكن ستستمر
الاشتباكات على الارجح لان
الوضع لا يزال متوترا خاصه وان يعني هناك
كثير من
المواجهات قد بدات في صباح الباكر من هذا
اليوم كانت هناك مواجهات عنيفه للغايه ثم
بعد هذه المواجهات التي استمرت لي اكثر من
ثلاث ساعات اعلنت بعدها قوه اعلنت بعدها
قوات الدعم السريع بسطه سيطرته على مطار
مروي الدولي
لكن هناك مقلق طبعا بطبيعه الحال يعتري
المواطنين خاصه في هذه الحاله الامنيه
المعقده خاصه وان حركه المواطنين باتت
مقيده للغايه ولم يعني يستطيع المواطنون
في اغلب الاحوال الحصول على
احتياجاتهم لاغلاق السوق اسواق المدينه
وبالتالي هناك يعني يريد غالبا هناك
احتماء داخل المنازل بالنسبه
للمواطنين هناك اخطار داهمه بطبيعه الحال
على الذين يقطنون في محيط مطار مروي
الدولي
ولانهم يعني على بعد كيليموترات قليله من
مسرح المواجهات العسكريه المسلحه بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
طيب فقط يعني بما انك تتحدث الامور تتركز
حول محيط المطار لكن باختصار لنعرف هل في
داخل المدينه هناك ايضا اشتباكات او
بالاحرى السؤال السيطره داخل المدينه لمن
هناك كثير من الاليات العسكريه التابعه
للجيش السوداني لم تتمكن حتى هذه اللحظه
قوات
القوات الدعم السريع من البسط من امتداد
بسط هذه السيطره اكثر من منطقه محيط
المطار والمطار نفسه لكن بحسب شهود عيان
ان هناك عدد من المركبات التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع قد وصلت الى الى مستشفى
المستشفى العسكري ولكن تراجعت ولم تتقدم
الى الامام لوجود عدد من الاليات وعدد من
الجلود الجنود الجيش السوداني الذين
يحيطون
بمستشفى الجيش في هذه المدينه ولكن هناك
ربما تكون معطيات قادمه جديده تفرض واقعا
ميدانيا جديدا سنكون معك بطبيعه الحال
اسامه سيدي احمد لمتابعه اي تطور جديد من
المروي مروي التي منها بدات هذه الازمه او
بدات منها الحشود والاشتباكات شكرا جزيلا
لك اسامه سيد احمد من مروي
الاشتباكات في السودان تدور حول مواقع
حيويه واستراتيجيه في التقرير التالي
نتعرف على ابرزها
[موسيقى]
كان مطار الخرطوم الدولي الذي يعد اكبر
مطارات البلاد والمقر الرئيسي للخطوط
الجويه السودانيه اول ضحيه للاشتباكات
التي اندلعت بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
اذ علقت كافه الرحلات الخارجيه والداخليه
كما تسببت الاشتباكات باضرار ماديه لعدد
من منشاته اضافه لاحتراق بعض الطائرات
المدنيه وقد حالات تعليق الرحلات في
المطار دون وصول وفدي مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي الى الخرطوم في حين لا يزال محيط
مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه وسط العاصمه مسرحا لاشتباكات
عنيفه بين الطرفين وسط تضارب في المعلومات
عن الجهه التي تسيطر عليه فعليا ويضم
المقر الذي سبق ان شهدت بواباته كبرى
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المطالبه بالحكم
المدني وزاره الدفاع وقيادات القوات
البحريه والبريه والجويه اضافه الى
الاستخبارات العسكريه القصر الجمهوري
الرمز السيادي للدوله لا يزال يشهد بدوره
اشتباكات عنيفه بين طرفي القتال ويقع في
اقصى الجزء الشمالي لمدينه الخرطوم ويضم
ايضا مكاتب اعضاء مجلس السياده مطار مروي
كان نشرق قوات الدعم السريع عشرات الاليات
العسكريه في محيطه بمنزله الشراره الاولى
لتفجر الخلافي مع الجيش ويغطي المطار
العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
ويحاذن مطار مروي المدني مطار عسكري ضخم
وقاعده جويه سبق لها ان استضافت مؤخرا
مناورات وتدريبات عسكريه مشتركه بين
الجيشين السوداني والمصري نقاط القتال
تضمنت ايضا كلا من مطار الاوبيض الذي يعد
المطار الرئيسي في ولايه شمال كردفان
ويربط غرب البلاد بالعاصمه كما يعتبر
مركزا لقوات الامم المتحده لحفظ السلام في
منطقه الى
مقابل الجنينه الذي يعد المطار الرئيسي في
ولايه غرب دارفور كما يربط ولايات دارفور
بباقي اجزاء السودان الاشتباكات في ولايه
الخرطوم الكبرى ادت الى تضرر عدد من
مستشفياتها وخروجها من الخدمه وسط معاناه
للعاملين فيها نقص الكوادر الطبيه
والمستلزمات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء ومن ابرز المنشات الطبيه التي
تضررت من الاشتباكات المستمره مستشفى
الشعب التعليمي مستشفى ابن سينا التخصصي
مستشفى البشائر اضافه الى مستشفى الخرطوم
الدولي
[موسيقى]
معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور ابراهيم محمد ادم
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بحري
مرحبا بك دكتور ابراهيم هل توافق الراي
القائل ان هذه المعارك وهذه الاشتباكات
تحدد على مدى سنوات قادمه المشهد السياسي
والعسكري في السودان وقد تكون منعطفا
تاريخيا في حياه السودان
نعم
هي معركه فاصله وتتحدث بموجب مسار للجيشر
للسوداني قوات الدعم هذه كانت قوه انشات
لمسانده الجيش بعدد محدود ولكن بعد
التغيير الذي حدث في ديسمبر تضخم حلم هذه
القوات كثيرا من 25 الف جندي الى ما يقارب
تقريبا 100000 وهي منتشره بكل انحاء
السودان كل المغاره لهيئه العمليات التي
كانت تتبعها لجهاز المخابرات وكانت هذه
القوه مقاتله عملت الاجانب المسلحه في
مناطق العمليات في دارفور وفي
جنوبان وفي الاميره المناطق النزاع وعندما
تم حل هذه اصبحت كلها في يد قوات الدعم
السريع هل هناك مغاره لمنظمات كانت تتبع
هذه الواجهات في عهد
دكتور ابراهيم
انقطع الاتصال مع الدكتور ابراهيم محمد
ادم استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بحري
شكرا جزيلا على اي حال
ونبقى في الخرطوم لكن مع الطاهر المرضي
مراسل الجزيره ليطلعنا على اخر التطورات
الميدانيه وما الذي يجري في هذه اللحظات
في الخرطوم الطائر
نعم بهذه اللحظات توقفت الاشتباكات
في هذه اللحظات لا نسمع اي نوع من
الاشتباكات او
الانفجارات
في هذه اللحظات تحديدا هذا الهدوء
الحجاب بعد الشبكات كانت عنيفه عند
حوالي الساعه 4 والساعه الثالثه وكانت
ايضا في صباح الباكر ولكن الان عاد الهدوء
الحذر الى
المدينه بعد ان بعد يوم طويل
الاوضاع الان بالنسبه للجوانب الانسانيه
هي اصبحت مغلقه وانا الاوضاع اصبح زائده
في التفاقم خاصه بعد النداءات التي
اطلقتها الكوادر الطبيه والالوان المتحده
والمنظمات الانسانيه بان المسارات التي
تحدثت عنها والالتزام بها يبدو ان هذه
الساعات الثلاث التي وافق فيها الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تصبح غير
كافيه لتحقيق هذا الغرض تحديدا لانه
الاوضاع ما تزال ماساويه وهنالك جرحى
وهنالك ايضا عمليات سيارات اسعاف تريد ان
تتحرك بامان خاصه ان الطرفين في هذا
النزاع يقولون ان هذه
الساعات او هذه الهدنه غير ملزمه بالنسبه
لهم اذا ما استغل اي طرف هذه الظروف وقام
باطلاق النار فلكل من طرفين يقول له حقا
في هذه الحاله وهذا ايضا اثار الخوف
بالنسبه
للكوادر الطبيه او حركتها في هذا الجانب
اذا اذا الامور تحتاج الى اليات تستطيع ان
تتحكم في هذه المساله الاوضاع الاخرى ايضا
هنالك محاولات ما تزال قائمه من الاحزاب
والشخصيات القوميه في السودان للتواصل
حتى
يتم اقناعهم بالدخول في مفاوضات ووقف
الدائم لاطلاق النار لان الاوضاع الان ما
تزال ماساويه وان استمرار الحرب سيؤدي الى
مزيد من التمزق الاعين الان ايضا تتجه الى
الاتحاد الافريقي والرئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي والى مجلس الامن
لمعرفه ما يمكن ان يصدر منهما يساعد الى
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار الاوضاع ايضا كذلك
في الولايات هنالك حديث انه هنالك
الاشتباكات في بعض الولايات في دارفور وفي
شمال كردفان كل هذه الامور الان تضع الحرب
هي سيده الموقف الان شكرا سيده الموقف
وليس هنالك اي مقترحات لوقف لاطلاق النار
او الاتجاه في هذا السير في هذا الاتجاه
شكرا جزيلا لك الطاهر المرضي الجزيره من
الخرطوم
ونعود الى الدكتور ابراهيم محمد ادم استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بحرين من
الخرطوم دكتور ابراهيم كنت تتحدث عن اثر
هذه المعارك في مستقبل السودان وما الذي
ستخلفه على صعيد العسكري والسياسي
لان يتم اصلاح امنيه بدمج كل القوات خارج
القوات
واحد وكانت عمليه
دمار
هي الاكثر تنظيما زوجته تكون مثالا لدمج
بقيه قوات الحركات المسلحه التي وقعت على
الاتفاقيه الكلام في هذه العمليه مهمه كان
فيها الحاسمه في عمليه
الايطالي لذلك تموت خلاف كبير جدا
الى عشره سنوات بالتاكيد وتنتظر ايضا على
قوات الحركات التالي
نعم دكتور ابراهيم
من جديد انقطع التواصل مع الدكتور ابراهيم
محمد ادم من الخرطوم نشكره جزيلا
قال رئيس مجلس سياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان في تصريحات لشبكه سي ان ان قائد
قوه الدعم السريع انتهك وقت اطلاق النار
المتفق عليه ويستغل ذلك لمواصله القتال
واضاف البرهان ان حمايه تمرد على الدوله
واذا القي عليه القبض سيحاكم امام القضاء
واوضح البرهان في تصريحته لسي ان ان قائد
قوات الدعم السريع يقود محاوله انقلاب اما
قائد قوه الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حماتي
فقال في تصريحات للسي ان ان ايضا انه ليست
لديه نيه لحكم السودان وانه يجب ان تكون
هناك حكومه مدنيه واضاف حمايه ان الجيش
انتهك وقت اطلاق النار المؤقت الذي توسطت
فيه الامم المتحده
وفي سلسله تغريدات على تويتر دعم محمد
حمدان حنيتي قائد قوه الدعم السريع
المجتمع الدولي الى تحرك فورا والتدخل
لوضع حد لما سماها جرائم الجنرال السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان واصفا اياه بالاسلاميه
المتطرف الذي يشن حمله وحشيه ضد الابرياء
ويقصفهم بالطيران على حد تعبيره وقال احمد
انه يحارب الاسلاميين الراديكاليين الذين
ياملون ابقاء السودان معزولا في الظلام
حسب وصفه متعهدا بملاحقه البرهان واعتبر
احمد تي ان المعركه التي تخوضها قوه الدعم
السريع هي ثمن الديمقراطيه نافيا ان تكون
قوته هي المبادره بالهجوم واضاف ان الدعم
السريع يتخذ كل الاجراءات الممكنه لضمان
سلامه وامن الناس متعهدا بحمايه
الديمقراطيه ودعم حكم القانون في السودان
في المقابل قالت الخارجيه السودانيه في
بيان موجه الى الراي العام والمجتمع
الدولي ان الاحداث المؤسفه التي يشهدها
السودان نتجت عن تمرد قوه الدعم السريع
على القوات المسلحه واضاف البيان ان رئيس
مجلس السياده اصدر قرارا بحل قوه الدعم
السريع واعلانها قوه متمرده وسيجري
التعامل معها على هذا الاساس
قدم مفوض الامن والسلمي في السودان
فولكرز في مؤتمر صحفي خلاصه حول مجريات
الوضع الميداني في البلاد وقال بيرتسن
القتال حتى الان لا يزال محصورا في طرفي
النزاع وقدره عدد القتلى المدنيين في
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه بنحو 180
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور بين القوتين
الاساسيتين منذ سبت الماضي لاحظنا وجود
تحركات لبعض الميليشيات القبليه وحتى الان
لا يزال القتال محصورا بين الجيشين
الرئيسيين تدور الاشتباكات بشكل كبير في
العاصمه الخرطوم والمطار مقفل مع وقوع
اشتباكات عنفه في محيطه وقربه مقر قياده
الجيش ومقر قوات الدعم السريع كذلك دارفور
ايضا تشهد قتالا عنيفا لاسيما في الفاشر
ونيالا قتل النتيجه الاشتباكات حتى الان
اكثر من 180 مدنيا واصيب ما يزيد على 1800
اخرين خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
معنا من نيويورك مراسله الجزيره بسان ابو
كويك بيسان جلسه لمجلس الامن ومواقف دوليه
لا سيما من الولايات المتحده بشان تطورات
السودان ماذا في اهمها وابرزها
حسنا طبعا الجلسه التي عقدتها او عقدها
مجلس الامن كانت جلسه مشاورات مغلقه قام
فيها فولكر بيرتس ايضا باحاطه اعضاء
المجلس لكنها انتهت دون صدور اي موقف جديد
وموحد عن المجلس يبدو ان الاعضاء اكتفوا
بذلك البيان الذي صدر في وقت متاخر من ليل
السبت ولكن سمعنا من عدد من
المندوبين والسفراء بصفتهم كممثلين
لبلادهم كالمندوبه الامريكيه لدى مجلس
الامن ليندا توماس جرين فيلد التي دعت
الى وقف الاعمال العدائيه فورا ودون شروط
مسبقه وتحدثت بشكل مباشر
مخاطبه الاطراف في السودان وقوات الامن
هناك
بالتخلي عن السلاح والبدء بالحديث وايضا
اكدت على ضروره محاسبه
الجهات الفاعله المسؤوله سياسيا او عسكريا
عن تقويض او تاجيل عمليات انتقال السودان
الى الديمقراطيه بالنسبه
سنعود اليك ولكن سنبقى في نيويورك معنى
ستيفاندو المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده مرحبا بك
الامين العام للامم المتحده اعرب عن القلق
حيال ما يجري ولكن هل من خطوات عمليه
قد يجري اتخاذها لوضع حد لهذا الصراع في
السودان
العمليه لنكن واضحين الشخصان الوحيدان
القديران على انهاء النزاع هما القائده
العسكريان اللذان يقودان هذه العمل لهذه
المواجهات بالنسبه الينا فان الامين العام
قد امضى معظم فترات نهايه الاسبوع على
الهاتف يتحدث الى القاده الاقليميين مسؤول
جامعه الدول العربيه والاتحاد الافريقي
وغيرهم نحن بحاجه الى جهود دوله منسقه
للضغط على الاطراف من اجل ايقاف العنف
الان
بالسودانز مبعوثه للامم المتحده في
السودان ايضا على اتصال بالطرفين والجميع
يعمل في المسار في الاتجاه نفسه الشعب
السوداني عاد بما فيه الكفايه ويجب ان
ننهي القتال الان
برايك لماذا لم يصدر اي موقف حازم وحاسم
من مجلس الامن الدولي في جلسته المغلق
باسمي مجلس الامن وباسم الاعضاء ال 15
يمكنني فقط ان اتحدث عما يقوم به الامين
العام سعاده السيد انطونيو غوتيرج ومنهم
موجودون على الارض وكانوا حاسمين حيث انهم
تواصلوا وفعلوا كل ما في وسعهم لوقف
القتال من المهم ان يذكر المشاهدون ان
الملايين من
السودانيين يعتمدون على المساعدات
الانسانيه التي توفرها الامم المتحده من
اجل ان ياكلوا وخلال حصول العمليات القتال
في السودان لا يمكننا ان ننفذ عملياتنا
الانسانيه طيب الامين العام للامم المتحده
اشرت الى سلسله من
الاتصالات التي
يجريها ما هي الاتصالات الابرز التي يعول
عليها الامين العام المتحده في محاوله
لوضع حد لهذا النزاع
الى
جنراللين مباشره خلال نهايه الاسبوع تحدث
ايضا الى الامين العام لجمع دول العربيه
ورئيس الاتحاد الافريقي تحدث الى الرئيس
السيسي وعدد من الاشخاص هناك اشخاص خارج
السودان لديهم تاثير على الاطراف هناك
اشخاص في السودان ايضا لديهم تاثير الجميع
عليه ان يعمل من اجل التوصل الى وقف فوري
لهذا العنف الذي لا منطقه له هو الذي
نشهده حاليا وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه الامم
المتحده وامينها العام في هذا المجال
في هذا المجال هو يفعل كل ما في وسعه لكي
يضمن استمرار الضغط على هذين القائدين
الجنرالين داخل السودان من اجل وقف القتال
ولكن ليس كل شيء بيده
الدفاع
لدينا منظمه
للتنميه وهي اقليميه وهي ايضا دورها مهم
الشعب السوداني يستحق ان يستعيد هذه
العمليه الانتقاليه الى الحكم المدني وان
توضع مره اخرى في المسار الملائم لا
يستحقون ان يروا استخدام الطائرات
المقاتله والقصف لدينا وجود كبير في
السودان ونحن موجودون لكي نساعد الشعب
السوداني وهذا هو هدفنا الوحيد من هو
الاكثر قدره على الضغط على طرفي النزاع
من الاطراف الدوليه والاقليميه او
المنظمات برايك
لا اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن شخص او
طرف اهم من غيره من المهم انه
او ان يتم نقل نفس الرساله بغض النظر عن
من يتحدثون الى هؤلاء الجنير او هذين
الجنرلين من المنطقه من افريقيا او من
الدول الاخرى يجب ان تنقل الرساله نفسها
على الصعيد على الصعيد
الامني والانساني هل يمكن ان تعمل الامم
المتحده وامين والعام على هدنه ثانيه من
اجل ادخال المساعدات او
مساعده المحتجزين
لقد عاملنا بالتنسيق مع شركاء اخرين في
الخرطوم حول حول توصل الى هدنه الى توقف
في القتال وفهمت انه هناك توقف قصير هذا
العصر على الناس ان يتمكنوا من الخروج من
منازلهم يحصلوا على الغذاء يطلب المساعده
لا يزال شهر رمضان ونحن نعرف ان ذلك يعني
ان ناس بحاجه للغذاء في فتره المساء
اذكركم باننا
اوقفنا مشاريعنا الانسانيه والاماميه تعرض
ثلاثه من برنامج الغذاء العالمي زملائنا
للقتل ايضا تعرضت مكاتب طبعا الامم
المتحده للنهب وللدمار وبالتالي تقع
المسؤوليه على قوه الدعم السريع وقوات
المسلحه السودانيه
لضمان امني العاملين
في المجال الانسانيه
وفريقنا المتحده لانه اذا عم يحصل ذلك سوف
يكون شبها مستحيلا بالنسبه الينا ان نقوم
بعملنا الذي هو مساعده الشعب
السودانيك المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده شكرا جزيلا لك
ونعود الى مراسله الجزيره في نيويورك بسن
ابو كويك اذا بعدما تابعنا
وهو يجيب على الاسئله المتعلقه بالوضع
الانساني وايضا
بالنشاط السياسي الذي يقوم به الامين
العام للامم المتحده نعود لسؤالك عن
المواقف الصادره بعد جلسه مجلس الامن ازاء
ما يحصل من صراع عسكري في السودان
طبعا حسن كما كنا قد اسلفنا المجلس لم
يعني يصدر عنه اي موقف
جديد سوى ذلك طبعا البيان الذي صدر قبل
يومين بعد جلسه المشاورات المغلقه سمعنا
من المندوبه الامريكيه
الدائمه بصفتها ممثله الولايات المتحده
هنا تدعو الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار ما
سمعناه من سفراء اخرين
كمندوب الروسي الدائم لدى الامم المتحده
يؤيد اي جهود لوقف التصعيد وهذا ما كان
يبدو ان يعني الاعضاء تنصب اهتمامهم عليه
وسمعنا ايضا من اعضاء او السفراء الدول
الاعضاء من افريقيا
قاموا ايضا بالادلاء بتصريحات مقتضبه
بالدعوه الى وقف القتال ودعم جهود منظمه
ايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي
التوصل لاي نوع من
التهدئه سمعنا ايضا من الممثل الاممي
الخاص بالكربرتس في تصريحات للصحفيين تحدث
عن الوضع على الارض اشعار الى انه حتى
اللحظه لم يوحي اي من الطرفين بانهما على
استعداد
للمضي قدما نحو مسار التسويه بالدعوه دعوه
كل طرف الاخر الى الاستسلام واشار الى ان
الوضع على الارض متذبذب بشكل لا يسمح
بالتنبؤ الى اي جهه ترجح الكفه في النهايه
وتحدث عن الجهود الانسانيه التي يبذلها من
اجل تسويات او التوصل لتسويه وقف مؤقت
لاطلاق النار لمده ثلاث ساعات لاغراض
انسانيه ولكن ما يقوم به من جهود حتى هذه
اللحظه ليست متعلقه باي تسويه اكبر او وقف
اكبر اطلاق النار سوى ذلك المتعلق
بالمساعدات الانسانيه شكرا لك
مراسله الجزيره من نيويورك
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم الباشا محمد
الباشا تطبيق
الكتب الصحفي والمحلله سياسي ومن الخرطوم
ايضا اللواء معتصم عبد القادر المستشار
بالاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه وسد معك السيد عبد القادر
بالحديث هنا عن تطور الامور
العسكريه على الارض وما يمكن ان تنتج من
تغير حتى على المستوى السياسي في البلاد
وعلى مستوى موازين القوى ووضع الجيش
الجزيره والتحيه للساده المشاهدين بالنسبه
انا اعتقد ان وضع الجيش الان في غايه
الكفاءه ويعمل بكفاءه عاليه ويضع في
اعتباره عدم احداث خسائر الوسط ارواح
وممتلكات الجماهير والشعب السوداني في
مختلف المناطق وهذا ما عطل بالعمليه لكن
نحن نعتقد ان هذه العمليه انتهت منذ اليوم
الاول بعد دخول الطيران وكسره لمعظم
القواعد داخل ولايه الخرطوم وفي الولايات
الاخرى في انحاء السودان المختلفه الان ما
يتم العمليات
تطهير وتمشيط وتنظيف بقايا
واما بالنسبه للوضع السياسي هنالك شيء ما
يدعوا
المفاوضات انا لا اعتقد انها تشمل بالنسبه
للقوات المسلحه الدعم السريع متمرده يجب
ان تعود الى حضن القوات المسلحه السودانيه
واليوم تم بقرار من القاعده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه وهذا من اختصاصه حسب
قوانين القوات المسلحه السودانيه حل الدعم
السريع ولا يوجد الان ما يسمى بالدعم
السريع الان هنالك افراد وعناصر من هذه
القوهيمون على وجوههم في شوارع الخرطوم
والمدن الاخرى ليس عليه الا الاستسلام
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه كي تكرمي
افادتهم اي تحركات اخرى منهم او اي عمل
مسلح سيعامل معامله المتمردين وكما ذكر
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
للقانون السوداني للعداله السودانيه كي
يحاكمها الجرائم التي ذكرها في حق الشعب
السود
نعم ابقى معنا السيد عبد القادر سيد
الباشا محمد الباشا تطبيق
ما رايك في في هذا القول بانه اساسا الان
ما يجري ليس الا عمليه تطهير
ويجب ان يحاكم محمد حمدان
حماتي ومن حق الجيش قانونا ان يحل او
البرهان ان يحل قوات الدعم السريع ما رايك
في هذا القول
شكرا لك
وشكرا لايف وتحيه للمشاهدين فاطمه
انا اؤكد لك يا استاذي الكريم نحن الان
ليس في مساله حل الدعم الشريحه او او يعني
وصفه يعني بتمرد او او يعني يعني
يعزمها كذا اوصاب نحن الان نحن الان في
معارك الان تقضي على الاخضر واليابس وتضرب
كل الشعب السوداني نحن الان على الارض لم
نسمع بحزمه واضح حتى الان الدعم السريع هو
الان وقوه الان موجوده انا اتكلم سياسي
لكن الواقع يكذب الشيء الان يعني
نحن الان نطالب بوصف اطلاق النار لانه من
يقتل هم ابرع الشعب السوداني سواء كانت
القوات المسلحه وكان في الدعم السريع نحن
نقدر يعني الشعب المسلحه وهي قوات عريقه
ولكن لكن الان ما يعني ما يحدث ما يحدث هو
يعني قد يؤدي
يعني
اي حرف
لكل بدايه الحرب لكن لا تستطيع بتجارب على
مستوى الدول وعلى مستوى يعني العالم اي
حرب يعني انت يعني يعني بداتها لا تستطيع
يعني في الاقامه نحن الان في اليوم الثالث
وهذا يعني يعني يؤثر على حركه المواطنين
ويؤثر على الدوله السودانيه والان هنالك
معاناه الشعب السوداني الان يعاني
والطيران العالي يعني يضرب وسط الاحياء
وسط يعني مناطق المختصه للسوداني هذا
الامر الان داخل العاصمه السودانيه عاصمه
السودان
نحن الان نتحدث عن محيط القياده العامه
على النظره الجمهوري الاذاعه
ان المعارك الخر
طوم هذا للتاكيد يؤثر على الشعب السوداني
يعني يزيد من المعاناه نحن الان نطالب
بوصف هذه الحرب شكرا
السودان ما يسمى بالرضاعيه والسلاثيه
التدخل العاجل هذه الحرب شكرا
السياسي من الخرطوم وشكرا ايضا لمعتصم عبد
القادر المستشار بالاكاديميه العليا وهو
لواء مستشار بالاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
على صعيد المساعي قال محمد الحسن لباس
مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
للجزيره قال ان تعليق الرحلات الى الخرطوم
ادى الى تاجيل زياره وفد المفوضيه مشيرا
الى ان اتصالات الاتحاد مستمره مع طرفي
الصراع في السودان
تجهز السيد
رئيس المفوضيه ومفوض الامن
والسلم السيد بانكولي ليذهب الى الخرطوم
اعترضت عارضه وهي ان المطار غير صالح مطار
الخرطوماني غير صالح البته حتى الان لنزول
الطائرات وكل الرحلات معلقه وقد تكون لحقت
به بعض الاضرار وحسب المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا لحد الساعه انه في منطقه غير امنه
لقرب
الصراع المسلحي منها ولربما فيها
وحالما تكون هنالك اي سانحه مهما كان
ضيقها سينتقل بحول الله هذا الوفد رفيع
المستوى
من الاتحاد الافريقي لبل كل المساعي
من لندن معنا جونا رئيس تحرير مجله افريكا
بريفينج والخبير بشؤون الافريقيه سيد
جونيفان
برايك هل بامكاننا الاتحاد الافريقي ان
يفرض حلا او على الاقل ان يتدخل بقوه
للضغط على الطرفين من اجل وضع حد لهذا
الصراع عسكريا على الاقل
الى الاتحاد الافريقي
وكافه الاطراف الاخرى يمكنهم ان يتدخلوا
من اجل تحقيق السلم في السودان ولكن الى
حد ما ولكن في النهايه الامر منوط
بالجنرلين الجنرال
احماتي والجنرال البرهان ان كل منهما
كيلو الاتهامات الى طرف الاخر
اذا يمكن الاتحاد الافريقي ان يحاول يحاول
ارساء السلام ولكن لن يحصل ذلك ما لم يرغب
الجنرال في ذلك ابقى معنا السيد جونا لان
في هذا المجال هناك اضافه لمحمد الحسن
لباس مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي حيث قال ان الاتحاد يسعى
بالتنسيق مع شركائه لان يكون الحل سودانيا
سودانيا وداخل القاره
نحن نرى ان لا فائده في اللجوء الى العنف
ونرى ان كل حل عسكري مهما اعطى
نقطه في الصراع لهذا الطرف او ذاك لن يشكل
حلا نهائيا للازمه العميقه في البلاد ولن
ينفذ الى جذورها وبالتالي فالمصلحه تقتضي
بكل المعاني ان يتوقف الاقتتال بسرعه
وبدون شرط وان يرجع كل الاطراف عسكريون او
مدرينا الى طاوله المفاوضات
لتخليص البلاد من الطامه الكبرى التي
اوقعها فيها هذا الصراع انه حبذ ان يكون
الحل حلا افريقيا سودانيا سودانيا بالدعم
الافريقي وان يبقى في اطار القاره
اعود اليه السيد جون فان مع تشعب هذه
الازمه الداخليا واقليميا وربما دوليا
ايضا هل يمكن ان تبقى معصوره في اطار
افريقيه كما ترغب المفوضيه
[موسيقى]
الى
نصف الاستقرار في منطقه اصلا
الاستقرار فيها متازازه
اثيوبيا قد وقعت على اتفاق بخصوص تيجراي
في نوفمبر جنوب السودان في وضع حساس
والصومال ومالي ايضا اذا ما يحصل في
السودان حاليا لا يؤشر بما هو ايجابي
للمنطقه ولكن من جهه اخرى
ارى انه هناك ضروره لتوصل الى حل لهذه
المشكله
ولكن اذا لم يشا اي من الاطراف ان يجلس
الى طاوله المفاوضات للتوقيع على اتفاق او
توصل الى حل ستكون حلول الوحيده هي حلول
عسكريه حيث يهزم طرف الطرف الاخر
ويجره حينذاك الى طاوله المفاوضات وهل
تعتقد بان طرفا بامكانه ان يهزم الطرف
الاخر وبالتالي يعني كيف يمكن ان يكون
عليه الوضع في المنطقه افريقيا اذا فعلا
تم لطرف او قيد له ان يهزم الاخر عسكريا
اعتقد ان الجنرال البرهان والجيش الذي
يقوده يمتلك
قوه اكبر
مقارنه بقوات الدعم السريع
والجنرالو اذا سوف يكون من الصعب على قوات
الدعم السريع او بالاحرى القوات السودانيه
ان تنهي قوات الدعم السريع
ما اراه هو امتداد لهذا النزاع بما لا
ينتهي ولكن اذا
راينا ان مصر تدعم
جيش الرسمي
بينما نرى الامارات والسعوديه
تدعم قوات الدعم السريع
اذا مصر والسعوديه والامارات
برايي يجب ان تجتمع وتناقش هذا الموضوع
وتضغط على الطرفين من اجل وقف فوري وتوصل
الى السلام شكرا لك
رئيس تحرير مجله افريكا والخبير بالشؤون
الافريقيه
قلل مين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو الوضع في السودان ادى الى خساره
ارواح مدنيين وان كل تصعيد اضافي سيكون
كارثيا للبلاد والمنطقه هذا واعلن نائب
رئيس نقابه الاطباء السودانيين خروج عدد
من المستشفيات عن الخدمه بسبب تعرضها
لاطلاق النار
صور كثيره ومرعبه عن الاقتتال بين حلفاء
الامس واعداء اليوم في السودان الاكثر
رعبا والى من وقسوه هو ما يعانيه الشعب في
ايام الجمر هذه صور تلك المعاناه قليله
جدا باستثناء بعض الفيديوهات على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي خلف الشوارع المهجوره
الا من المتناحرين على السلطه السودانيون
عالقون في بيوتهم او في اخر مكان كانوا
فيه قبل ان يتفجر الوضع ليحول الخرطوم الى
ساحه حرب مفتوحه القتلى في صفوف المدنيين
بالمئات يستعصي الحصول على اعداد رسميه
دقيقه في ظل صعوبه التنقل والاتصالات يدق
الاطباء والعاملون في المجال الانساني
نقوص الخطر بعض احياء العاصمه الخرطوم
بلماء ولا كهرباء منذ السبت الماضي فشلت
الهدنه الانسانيه الاولى الاحد لم يستطع
الطرفان التوقف عن الاقتتال لثلاث ساعات
فقط الم وافق عليها ولم تحترم عبر مفرد
الامم المتحده الى السودان فولكربرس عن
خيده امله الشديده وانزعاجه مما اعتبره
انتهاكات الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع لتلك الهدنه الانسانيه
المريضه اصلا هي الان في حاله يرسلها هذه
لقطات لتسجيل بالهاتف المحمول من داخل
احدها لدواء ولا خدمات ولا امكانيه للخروج
من المستشفى بسبب تبادل اطلاق النار
الطواقم الطبيه في حاله عجز تام وسط
انعدام كليا للامن داخل المبنى الذي
اخترقته رصاصات وقذائف الوضع صعب للغايه
تحذر منظمه الصحه العالميه جاء في بيانها
المقلق ان عددا من مستشفيات الخرطوم
التسعه التي تستقبل المصابين تعاني من
نفادي وحدات الدم ومعدات نقل الدم وسوائل
الحقن الوريدي وغيرها دعوه الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش الى وقف
فوري للاعمال العدائيه قد لا تجد لها
مستجيبا واستفاوض السلاح والبارود
ادى الوضع الى خسائر فادحه في الارواح
فيهم العديد من المدنيين اي تصعيد اخر قد
يكون مدمرا للبلد والمنطقه احس كل من له
تاثير في الوضع على استخدامه من اجل
السلام ودعم الجهود المبذوله لانهاء العنف
واستعاده النظام والعوده الى مسار
الانتقال كان الوضع الانساني في السودان
محفوفا بالمخاطر بالفعل وهو الان كارثي
الاسوا ربما ات في غياب اي مؤشر لاخماد
نيران الفتنه قريبا وكان المصائب لا تاتي
فرادى علقت منظمه الاغذيه العالميه نشاطها
مؤقتا في السودان السبب مقتل ثلاثه من
موظفيها في دارفور وتضرر طائره تابعه لها
جراء الاشتباكات في مطار الخرطوم يحتاج
اكثر من ثلث سكان السودان البالغ عددهم 45
مليونا الى مساعده انسانيه
قبل ان تصلهم ينبغي ان يسكت السلاح في بلد
كان قبل سنوات قليله يؤمن ويهتف ويناضل من
اجل الحريه والتغيير الديمقراطي سلبت
الامال والارواح واخذ السودان الى دوامه
عنف يقول البعض انها لم تحدث منذ استقلاله
في خمسينيات القرن الماضي من يراف بالعباد
في هذا المشهد المسخن بالازمات والجروح
ومتى سيعد الصفاء الى سماء السودان وارضه
تنضموا الينا من نيروبي
اليوناكو المتحدثه الاقليميه باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر سيده اليانا
نود ان نعرف منك عمل اساليب الاحمر في
ضوء ما يجري حاليا في السودان والتحديات
التي تواجه
وكيف ينسق عملياته داخل السودان في ظل
الاشتباكات
بالنسبه الى تحديات فهي كثيره
لقد شاهدنا ثلاثه ايام من القتال الذي لم
ينقطع هذا اليوم حين تحدثت الى فريقين في
الخرطوم قالوا ان الليل شهد بعض الهدوء
وناموا قليلا ولكن في الصباح
سؤنثات المواجهات وكان هناك شظايا ورصاص
والقتال يحصل بالقرب من مناطق سكنيه
كثيفه بالسكان وبالتالي دخلت الشظايا الى
مكاتبنا بالنسبه الى الوضع الحالي فهو لا
يسمح لفريق عملنا بالتنقل بطريقه سهله
وحره ليقوم بعمله وهذا هو تحدي الاكبر لا
يستطيع ان يقوم
بعمله
فقط بسبب الاشتباكات
وليس بامكانه الدخول الى مناطق العمليات
العسكريه
بالنسبه الى العمليات العسكريه فهي تحصل
داخل المدينه يعني مثلا كان هناك
اشتباكات مكثفه بالقرب من المطار واذا
نظرت الى خريطه الخرطوم عرفت ان المطار
اصلا يقع بالقرب من مناطق سكنيه مقتضى
بالسكان بالقرب من مقر مكاتبنا بالتالي
هذا الوضع لم يسمح لفريق عملنا بالتنقل
بتعريقه حره اذا نظرت الى شوارع وجدتها
مهجوره ليس فقط من فريق عملنا بل ايضا
المدنيين تريدون اتصالات مستمره من مدنيين
عالقنا فيما اماكن مختلفه مثل السوق
والمطار
ينفذ لديهم الطعام الماء اذا هذا الوضع
بدا يقترب من الوضع الميؤوس منه ايضا
اولويتنا الان هي ان نصل الى المستشفيات
لان المستشفيات ينقصها المياه والكهرباء
وبدات امداد طبيه تنفذ وحتى الان لم ننجح
في ذلك داخل مدينه الخرطوم يعني شرط
الصليب الاحمر او الهلال الاحمر
اليست او الا يفترض ان تكون درعا يعني هل
سيارات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
تتعرض ايضا
للقصف او حتى لاطلاق النار
هي يفترض بها ان تكون درعا نتحدث عن
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر وهي رموز او
هذا رمز او شعار يفترض به ان يحمينا وان
يحمي المستجبين الاوائل ويمكنهم من التحرك
بطريقه حره لكي يصل الى المصابين لكي
يرفعوا الجثث بطريقه محترمه ولائقه لكي
يوفروا العلاج الذي ينقذ الارواح ولكن
القتال كان مكثفا لدرجه انه تعذر
النزول الى الشارع والتحرك طريقه حره
في الخارج حتى الان نحن تواصلنا مع وقد
دعونا وجهنا نداءات في محادثات خاصه او
عامه وتوجهنا فيها الى كل من هم مشاركون
لكي يسمحوا لنا بالتحرك بطريقه حره لكي
يسمحوا لي فريق المسعفين والفريق الطبي
بان يخرج ويقوم بواجبه لا سيما للمدنيين
لان الناس يشعرون بذعر كبير وينفذ منهم
المياه والطعام اليوم
المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر شكرا جزيلا لك
ينقضي اليوم الثالث من المعارك في السودان
على صوره ضبابيه وتضارب في الانباء حول
السيطره الميدانيه لطرفي الصراع وتتركز
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع على المطارات ومراكز السياده في
غياب اي مبادرات للتهدئه وقد برز موقف
لقائد قوات الدعم محمد حميطي قال فيه انه
يحارب ما دعاه الاسلام الراديكالي ما منح
الصراع بعدا سياسيا مختلفا
لا صوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص عزيزي
الطائرات وهدير الدبابات في المدينه
المتحوله الى ميادين قتال بغتا الناس في
اشغالهم وبيوتهم وحاصر الاطفال في المدارس
والمرضى في المستشفيات معالم الماساه
تتعاظم مع كل ساعه من حرب عنوانها
البيانات المتضاربه عن تقدم احد الطرفين
الجيش السوداني بقياده الجنرال عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
الجنرال محمد حمدان حماتي ويعمق الغموض
خطرا انحدار حرب الاخوه حلفاء الامس اعداء
اليوم الى صراع يستوطن الشوارع والمدن
والولايات وهي جاريه فعلا شرقا في كسله
وشمالا في مروي وغربا في الفاشر ونيالا
حواضر دارفور انها بلاد شاسعه معقده
التشابك القبلي مضخمه
المستنفري لاي شراره في اليوم الثالث على
الارض معارك عنيفه تركزت حول مطار العاصمه
ومطار مروي في سعي محموم للسيطره على
المطارات حيث يتفوق الجيش بسلاح الجو فيما
قوه الدعم السريع بالاليات والمدرعات
الصغيره خفيفه الحركه سريعه الاختفاء وبثت
قوه الدعم صورا قالت انها من داخل مقر
البرهان في مبنى القياده العامه خبر نفاه
الجيش ورد بانه يلاحق من سماه بالمتمردين
الذين يفرون في كل اتجاه ويتحصنون بين
الاهالي وفق بيانه ومع انفجار صراع
الايرادات حربا مخيفه وضع حمايه اخيرا
اطارا لها ابعده من صراع على السلطه عندما
اعلن انه يقاتل ما وصفه بالاسلام
الراديكالي متهما البرهان بانه متطرف يشن
حربا على الديمقرا التي يحميها هو ثم ذيل
قوله بدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى اتخاذ موقف
ورد عليه المعسكر المضاد بتاريخه لقد برز
محمد حمدان ديجلو او حمايه ابن دارفور من
حروب الواقع ضد التمرد هناك مطلع الالفيه
قاتل لصالح الحكومه ذات التوجه الاسلامي
مجردا من انتماء سياسي او ايديولوجي انه
تاجر قوه وفق خصومه تعلم الحياه والحرب في
مواضعها لا في المدارس ثم صعدت قواته التي
تحمل اسم الدعم السريع الى مصاف القوى
الشرعيه في زمن الرئيس عمر البشير الذي
اطيح به بتكافل بين حماتي نفسه والمؤسسات
العسكريه اما البرهان وفق مناصري الجيش
فهو الجنرال القادم من قلب المؤسسه مترقيا
اركان جيشا ما عاد يحتمل جيشا موازيا يعصى
على الدمج بطموحات لا حدود لها
امن البلاد وتجعلها
رهينه الفوضى
علامه ستنتهي الحرب يترقب الجميع جلاء
غبار المعارك لتعرف الدول على اي جنبيها
تميل والغبار يزيد خانقا باعثا الفزعه في
مشهد يختزله سلاح مختلف النشاه والجذر
غامض الوجهه